hello I'm Ewan McGregor and I play
Christopher Robin today I'm taking the
BuzzFeed quiz which Winnie the Pooh
character are you so the first question
is how do you like to eat your honey
straight out of the jar on your toast on
your pizza on your pancakes on your
fruit in your tea I would take it
straight out of the jar how would your
best friend describe you ambitious
optimistic introverted loving hilarious
adventurous I think probably adventurous
oh that would be telling
I wouldn't be still description
descriptors to say choose a disney
princess to join you on an adventure for
the sake of my daughter's it's gonna
have to be Elsa how do you like to spend
your free time cooking exercising
hanging out with friends and family
watching TV
traveling sleeping ooh the truth is
there's quite a few of those is sleeping
traveling and hanging out with friends
and family so I'm gonna have to choose
between those three I'm gonna choose
hanging out with friends and family and
then describe your laughs in one word
deep infectious loud soft rambunctious
or maniacal I would like to hope it was
infectious
you got Winnie the Pooh hey oh honey you
are a highly curious individual who is
equal parts lovable and charming you're
a thoughtful person who knows exactly
how to turn someone today from dreadful
to wonderful friends stick to you like
honey because there's no one else quite
like you Winnie the Pooh oh I'm
delighted I got Winnie
because he's my man I think they've got
it absolutely right
[Music]